[Aplausos]
[Música]
tenía siete años apenas apenas siete
años que siete años no llegaba cinco
siquiera de pronto unas voces en la
calle me gritaron negras
[Música]
soy acaso negra me dije que conoces ser
negra y yo no sabía la triste verdad que
aquello es con bien y me sentí negra
como ellos decían y retrocedí como ellos
querían
y odié mis cabellos y mis labios huesos
y miri apelada mi carne tostada y
retrocede y retrocede
[Música]
y pasaba el tiempo y siempre amargada
seguía llevando a mi espalda me pesaba
carga y como pensaba me alas y el
cabello
devolvé la cara y entre mis entrañas
siempre resonaba la misma palabra
[Música]
y hasta que un día que retrocedían
retrocedía y que iba a caer
[Música]
y hoy soy sí soy negra negra soy que hoy
en adelante no quiero hacer mi cabello y
voy a reírme de aquellos que por evitar
según ellos que por evitarnos algún
sinsabor llaman a los negros gente de
color y de qué color y qué lindo suena y
qué ritmo tiene
[Música]
al fin al 5 prendido ya no retrocedo
avanzó segura avanzó y esperó y bendigo
el cielo porque quiso dio generosa base
fuese mi color y ya comprendí ya tengo
la llave
negra soy
[Música]